FEMALE SPEAKER: What is the
biggest challenge designers
face currently?
JENNA BILOTTA: The
biggest challenge
designers are
facing today is how
to describe their
value to non-designers.
ADAM DEBRECZENI: Moving from a
static medium to a dynamic one.
MIKE SIMONIAN: To
anticipate change.
BRANDON WALKIN: Designing
in an interactive medium.
ROMAN NURIK: We need
more and better tools.
NOAH LEVIN: Tools.
I think we have a hard
time getting out our ideas.
We have great ideas.
I think everyone
has great ideas.
But finding a way to get
them out into the world
is really the harder part.
MAAIKE EVERS: To find simplicity
in all the complex systems
that we're tackling today.
ISABELLE OLSSON:
Hardware and software
moving so quickly that
we don't have enough time
to put our hearts
and souls into it.
VICTORIA SLAKER:
That's speed to market.
JOSH MORENSTEIN: Speed
to market and inability
to spend enough time
refining your ideas.
MOLLY STEVENS: So many
problems, so little time.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
What do you think
is the biggest
challenge designers
will face in the future?
SCOTT DOORLEY: I
think technology
will become more complex and
have more moral questions.
BRADEN KOWITZ: We are
building more and more complex
interfaces for people.
And people are changing the way
they behave faster and faster.
And that makes design
such a challenge.
PAUL COLTON: The complexity
of future devices
and capabilities.
MICHAEL DITULLO: As we
continue to interact further up
the value chain
with organizations,
how do we remain designers?
MITCH HEINRICH: I think
managing complexity,
keeping things simple.
CHAD THORNTON: I think it's the
same challenges they've always
faced.
It's both having the vision
and realizing the vision.
RYAN FREITAS: I think the
challenges are very old.
They're trying to make
something beautiful, useful,
and well-built.
JENNY ARDEN: I really
believe that design
will be a greater part of
leadership in all companies.
I am really looking
forward to a designer
actually being more
like a CEO at companies.
And so I think
designers will have
the challenge of having
the emotional connection
to the work, and to users, but
also having business sense.
[MUSIC PLAYING]